let's get the very latest from the
shadow work and pension secretary now
Jonathan Ashworth is here before we
start on other matters can I just ask
you we had the chair of the select
committee Caroline dinage on the program
a little bit earlier and she says that
ITV bosses have a lot of questions to
answer over what happened with Phillip
Schofield and this unnamed Runner well
I've got to be honest I haven't followed
the twists and turns as closely as
perhaps Caroline has but from what I've
seen it does suggest that there are
questions for icv I think there is an
internal inquiry taking place but it
does seem appropriate that the chair of
the culture and media select committee
looks into this further which is what I
assume she is suggesting she's going to
do and Dave so we'll wait and see what
happens as far as that is concerned
um also I wanted to ask you about
migrant barges will labor keep them the
ones
look I mean the problem of this is that
uh Rishi sunak keeps sort of boasting
that he's got a plan to grip the
situation and actually he isn't really
dealing with the criminal gangs the
people Smugglers he refuses to go after
them in fact you've seen very prominent
conservative MPS saying these criminal
gangs will always be with us as if we
should just sort of give up on going
after the criminal gangs what have that
Cooper's done she's our shoulder Home
Secretary as as you know she's outlined
a detailed plan as to how we will go
after these criminal gangs but we've
also got a deal with the backlog in
Asylum processing and this backlog bill
that's going through Parliament isn't
going to fix this backlog if you fix the
backlog in Asylum processing well less
of uh if you like an appropriate
destination for these criminal gangs to
exploit so these are the these are the
measures that we would introduce to deal
with these problems would you keep the
barges well we would hope that we
wouldn't need the barges of course
because we would we would be dealing
with the Asylum backlog and would be
going after the criminal game
but in the meantime I mean there's a
hundred thousand people 144 000 people
let's say a third of them uh are are
re-homed or whatever by the time if you
get into Power you still got a hundred
thousand what would you do with them
well I guess let's see where we are in
you know in a year of 18 months time
when we're closer to a general election
but at the moment we're putting forward
a detailed plan to actually deal with
the people Smugglers the criminal gangs
and to deal with the the backlog in
Asylum processing so how would you deal
with that how would you deal with
processing those that are coming over in
small boats given that there's so many
people here at the moment well well you
what you should do you should invest
properly in uh in policing and security
and work cooperatively across border on
that and we're not doing that at the
moment and the processing and the Asylum
system that that's our backlogs in the
home office so you've got to get a
better system in place I feel something
like only one percent of uh uh of the uh
applications for those who Cross by
boats last year was processed that's
crazy and the and the Asylum backlog has
just gone through the
I'm not going to give you specific
figures today but I mean it's something
I doubled off something like that under
the conservances and you could bring it
back down to a manageable number and at
the moment it's because everybody knows
that they've got this huge backlog in
Asylum cases where people can go for
months and months and months and months
and months with not getting a decision
if you're even longer than months and
months uh in some circumstances that
means the criminal gangs exploit that
situation and that is the root of this
problem
um let me ask you about Dale Vince who
owns ecotricity um he told he was
actually he was down the line he spoke
to me yesterday on the show he said he
probably would protest with just stop
oil
um
and we've heard from your boss who said
that his friends just stop oil is
concerned they should just go home
you've also taken one and a half million
pounds from delvin's I mean is there any
conflict of interest there no no no no I
mean Dale Vince has donated a labor
party who else he wants to donate to
that's his decision but what kirstan was
outlining today is a plan to rebuild our
economy to make our economy both more
prosperous and more productive and to
create thousands hundreds of thousands
of good well-paying skill jobs in the
future energy sectors which is important
because it will bring down bills for
every household across the country
yeah but is it supporting a group that
break the law we're not supporting a
group we're not remembering he he is
supporting the group that breaks the law
of jail events well that's his decision
I mean who he supports is up to him but
if he but if he wants to donate to the
level queasy at all that well it's his
decision just because he's donated to
the lower party does not mean we endorse
the other decisions he makes as to where
he puts his money but what we are
outlining today is a really big plan to
create hundreds of thousands of good
well-paid jobs and bring down energy
bills for every household across the
country and then and that is not
happening under the conservatives at the
moment in fact one of the conservatives
after 13 years the economy isn't a mess
nothing works in the country we've got
no growth in the economy we've actually
got levels of employment lower now than
they were before the pre-data before the
pandemic nothing works in the country
there's a little bit of a sweeping
generalization but no it does work I
mean you can't get a Hospital
appointment you can't get a GP
appointment you know you know the
schools are collab are collapsing the
economy is a is a mess everyone is
paying more on their mortgage as a
consequence of the decisions this
conservative government has made so I
think nothing does work and we've got
some bloke who's giving money to an
organization that he knows and we all
know who breaks the law and it doesn't
make you at all queasy that he's also
giving money to your party but who he
gives money to is up to him we don't
agree with just we don't agree with just
a pile I don't agree with them uh
throwing orange powder or you know or
disrupting the snooker and all the other
things that they are doing that is no
way to win over hearts and minds but who
he gives his money to is up to him what
we're focused on is a plan to rebuild
our economy create hundreds of thousands
of good well-paying jobs in our economy
and bringing energy bills down for every
house we've also got a former Extinction
Rebellion legal strategist working for
labor nights it's quite a build up of
activism influence in your party no no
what we are influenced by is what is in
the interests hard-working families out
there and we know they're really
struggling they're going to be paying
more on their mortgage because the
decisions about this conservative
government they're paying more on their
weekly their weekly shop at the
supermarket because the government's
failed to tame inflation the jobs that
are out there but don't pay enough for
people to build a home and to build a
family life which is why we are focused
on hard-working families to create an
economy where bills are coming down
where people are better off and whether
a good well-paid jobs for the future